pour le panel on retrouve dont deux
chefs de bureaux madeleine blé morin à
ottawa sébastien bovet keita québec mon
sort à vous deux mais vraiment ce qui a
marqué la journée ce sont ses excuses du
pape aux premières nations au métier
toutes ces délégations qui ont passé la
semaine à rome qui aurait eu l'occasion
d'avoir des audiences avec le pas pour
raconter leurs histoires à raconter ce
qu'ils ont vécu madeleine il faut dire
que tout ça ces excuses c'était dans les
recommandations de cette comité vérité
comme réconciliation oui la commission
vérité et réconciliation qui avaient
entendu les témoignages de dizaines
centaines probablement même des milliers
de victimes des pensionnats autochtones
et qui était arrivé avec une des 94
recommandations qui demandait des
excuses du pape non seulement des
excuses du pape mais des excuses du pape
ici au canada donc la commission n'avait
pas choisi cette recommandation au
hasard elle savait que c'était important
pour les victimes des pensionnats
autochtones de qu'on reconnaisse
finalement officiellement par la bouche
du saint-père du du saint-père lé les
torts qui ont été commis dans ces
pensionnats autochtones donc je vous
dirais que c'est une cage qui est une
case qui est à moitié cochet aujourd'hui
parce que si les mots qui ont été
prononcés étaient très importants mais
on attend maintenant qu'il soit
prononcée à nouveau au canada où il ya
eu des réactions politiques aussi la
part de justin trudeau entre autres
justin trudeau qui se dit bon c'est
grâce aux victimes c'est grâce aux
histoires qu'elles ont raconté que le
pape a finalement formuler ses excuses
il dit lui aussi que c'est un premier
parc la réconciliation elle c'est un
chemin qui va être long c'est le genre
de discours que justin trudeau
prenons souvent lorsqu'il est question
de la réconciliation avec les peuples
autochtones
mais c'est quand même aussi une bonne
nouvelle pour justin trudeau parce que
lorsqu'il a pris le pouvoir en 2015 et
il avait accepté toutes les
recommandations les 94 en disant on va
travailler à ce qu'elles soient toutes
mises en oeuvre même si on a plusieurs
qu'il n'était pas de son ressort les
excuses du pape évidemment c'est pour
lui qu'ils pouvaient les bras non c'est
mais il y en a d'autres aussi qui relève
des provinces on parle par exemple du
système de justice on parle du système
de santé on parle de l'éducation
plusieurs recommandations sont dans la
cour des provinces et elles ne sont pas
toutes mises en oeuvre jusqu'à
maintenant donc c'est une étape
aujourd'hui mais une étape d'un long
chemin vers la réconciliation par l'on
donne des problèmes justement celle du
québec c'est basescu les réactions sur
la scène provinciale au québec j'ai
regardé et rapidement sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment on n'avait pas accès
aux aux élus aujourd'hui mais sur les
réseaux sociaux pas de réaction je n'en
ai pas vu ce qu'il veut pas dire que je
que les gens ici ne salue pas la
décision du pape de de transmettre ses
excuses c'est comme si on avait besoin
que ceux ci comme accélérer le processus
avec le pape à partir du moment où les
sépultures ont été trouvés dans les
dents les pensionnaires qui avait une
pression additionnelle pour que l'église
reconnaisse d'une certaine façon c'était
plus que ces excuses soit faite
aujourd'hui avec cette étape là qui est
franchi mais qui règlent évidemment pas
tout ce qui toutes les demandes qui sont
faites par les communautés autochtones
donc pas de réaction comme tel cependant
eu des reproches aujourd'hui et ça
venait de badauds massés québec
solidaire qui reprochaient la caq de pas
tenir ses engagements envers les
premières nations on a pris un petit
extrait du communiqué que québec
solidaire
envoyé aux médias alors elle dit ceci
entre autres choses elle c'est honteux
en brisant sa promesse ministre la
fronière affiche encore plus les
communautés autochtones et porte
atteinte à la mémoire de joyce et chaque
one en fait ici elle dit qu'il n'a pas
respecté son engagement d'inscrire ce
principe de sécurité culturelle à
l'intérieur de la loi sur la santé et
les services sociaux mais je le vérifie
avec vous c'est bcf qu en effet monsieur
lafreniere y renoncer en fait il y a
renoncé pour cette session parlementaire
ça veut dire qu'il y renonce jusqu'aux
élections si bien que si jamais cette
notion de sécurisation culturel est
incorporé à la loi sur la santé ce sera
seulement dans les prochains mois au
cours de la prochaine année peut-être ou
des deux prochaines années ça permet de
faire le pont c'était ce qui s'est passé
ici à l'assemblée nationale avec la
sécurisation culturel avec les excuses
du pape stadium il ya des étapes qui
sont franchies mais ça ne règle pas tout
par exemple la sécurisation culturel qui
est essentiellement le fait de dans le
réseau de la santé quand des gens qui
donnent des soins font affaire avec des
autochtones une réalité particulière
dont il faut être conscient il ya une
communication particulière qui doit se
faire il ya un code aussi qui est pas le
même code que avec les autres patients
donc qu il faut donner des services et
des soins qui sont sécurisants pour les
autochtones à travers le réseau de la
santé alors le ministre la première
s'était engagé à l'inclure dans la loi
sur la santé
or il sera pas capable de le faire et
donc on a beau franchir des étapes
parfois avoir des engagements de la
classe politique pour changer les choses
dans la réalité c'est pas toujours
facile de provoquer le changement est de
sécuriser ce genre mais madame marcelle
a souligné d'autres pointent aussi dans
le même communiqué d'ailleurs elle a
repris des propos qui viennent des
premières nations cette semaine au
québec entre autres sur la décision de
monsieur jocelyn bar est de refuser de
reconnaître les langues autochtones dans
la loi la décision du ministre berges de
ne pas créer un protecteur de l'élève
autochtone alors ça commence à
s'additionner tout ça cette semaine est
un drôle de contexte parce qu'on est
dans la semaine justement où le pape lui
offrent ses excuses oui il ya les la
question de la formation aussi du
personnel la socri la réalité autochtone
on devait atteindre la moitié des
travailleurs de la santé formés au 31
mars nous sommes le 1er avril et il ya
30 % des travailleurs qui ont été formés
donc
évidemment il ya eu la pandémie et puis
parfois ça va pas vite mais c'est comme
si la mort de joyce et chaque one a
servi d'électrochoc pis on parlait de la
découverte des sépultures tout à l'heure
dd dans les pensionnats autochtones
c'est un peu le même électrochoc au
canada mais il faut faire des suivis et
puis des fois les suivent ils
n'aboutissent pas ou en tout cas pas
dans le calendrier qu'on espère ouais
quand parler des recommandations des
suivis de commissions aussi à leur
commission vérité réconciliation sur la
scène fédérale sur la scène provinciale
baisse est la commission vient à la
suite des enquêtes qu'on connaît aussi
mais là il ya cette autre grosse étape
je me demande jusqu'à quel point le
fédéral est responsable aussi de ça
cette visite du pape qui est très
attendu où on entendu le témoignage
tantôt d'un chef que j'avais en entrevue
pour eux c'est extrêmement important que
le pape vienne ici sur le territoire
présenté les excuses et le chef que
j'avais en entrevue disait j'espère
qu'il repose juste dans l'ouest j'espère
qu'ils vont venir aussi dans notre
communauté ou à tout le moins dans le
secteur de québec à sainte anne de
beaupré peut-être dans le cadre de cette
période de pèlerinage de fête de sainte
anne madeleine
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est la
visite d'un pape pour le pour le fédéral
pour le gouvernement mais j'imagine que
ça veut dire quand même pas mal
d'organisation mais c'est quand même
comme je le disais tout à l'heure julie
ce serait une bonne nouvelle pour le
gouvernement canadien parce que ça
participerait ça contribuerait à cette
réconciliation
j'entendais madame odette sur vos ondes
tout à leur dire les sévices ils ont été
commis ici donc on attend le pape ici la
recommandation demandé que le pape
vienne prononcer ses excuses au canada
est le chef piétacho que vous aviez en
entrevue disait bon moi je suis allé au
pensionnat autochtone j'aimerais bien
qu'il vienne au québec aussi il ya eu
des expériences individuelles un peu
partout au pays évidemment il ya eu un
accord collectif mais il ya eu aussi
plusieurs petites or individuel qui ont
été causés et qui ont eu des
répercussions
multigénérationnel donc c'est un peu
normal que les premières nations qui ont
été qu'ils ont passés à travers ce
processus pénible des pensionnats
autochtones sans qu'elles méritent aussi
ces personnes-là des excuses dans leur
coin de pays chez eux chez elle donc on
verra bien comment ça va articuler tout
sort n'a pas encore de date de ne pas
encore de logistique on ne peut pas
encore de deux programmes officiels mais
de toute façon je pense que s'il vient
au canada le pape se serait à en prenons
ça encore une fois des excuses je pense
que ce serait une grande étape on n'a
pas de date annoncée qu'une préférence
pour l'été ça touche contre ce qu il est
et je dirais que ça tousse tousse à
apaiser un peu l'atmosphère alléger
l'atmosphère et non en effet ça c'est
del en réalité on va parler un petit peu
de la coved aussi des décisions qu'on
attend une sorte de suspense au québec
sébastien sur le masque est ce que c'est
lundi effectivement condrey avant
l'heure juste à savoir si on garde ou
pas après le 15 avril le directeur de la
sûreté publique a dit qu'ils
transmettraient sa recommandation au
gouvernement
vous savez il ya cette réunion de la
cellule de crise tous les lundis à 18h30
on pense que c'est a toujours lieu quoi
que le gouvernement s'est
publiquement beaucoup moins actif pour
gérer la coved qui veut pas dire que en
coulisses il ne l'est pas alors c'est
possible que lundi en fait c'est ce pont
c'est ce à quoi on s'attend lundi
monsieur boileau le docteur bouallou
transmettre ses recommandations pour
arrêter par tellement ce que dit le 15
avril ou le maintenir un peu plus la
question il ya énormément de pression
actuellement sur lui le docteur boulot
pour maintenir le masque de la pression
qui vient du milieu scientifique des
gens qui disent allons-y prudemment
gardons le masque encore un peu parce
que c'est une bonne barrière alors en
principe le gouvernement devait nous
dira mardi si le masque allait être levé
dix jours plus tard c'est à dire le 15
avril donc on s'attend à une annonce
lundi ou mardi sur la suite des choses
oui il ya le masque dans les lieux
publics mais il y aurait aussi la
question des écoles avec 75% de aux
absences d'élèves et d'enseignants aussi
depuis une semaine au québec qui on voit
quel point ça mais les écoles dans des
situations un peu délicate parce qu'une
école c'est décident d'imposer le mac
est un peu toujours à bord un enseignant
ou un parent qu'ils écoutaient c'est pas
obligatoire du propos nous oblige il ya
peut-être signal qui doit venir de santé
publique est ce que le signal ça
pourrait être de dire on enlève le
masque à partir du 15 avril mais on vous
le recommande encore fortement parce que
ça pourrait de dire on maintient un mois
de plus actuellement au pays cela étant
dit à ma connaissance il n'y a qu'une
seule autre province l'élu presse edward
qui maintient le port du masque toutes
les autres provinces de façon générale
dans la majorité des lieux publics ont
suspendu le port du masque donc il ya
aussi ça qui joue dans la proche de la
population succès en juin tout le monde
dit oui mais pourquoi pas lui mais
rooney pourquoi juste - ayem sait que
cet effet là mais ce qu'on a compris
madeleine on va terminer là dessus c'est
que la santé publique aujourd'hui
fédéral qui disait ben écoutez la
sixième banque avait pas son entrée au
même rythme dans toutes les provinces
est un vaste pays et tout se passe pas
de la même façon oui alors c'est pour ça
que la santé publique fédérale ne parle
pas en ce moment de sixième bague à
l'échelle nationale elle ne disait pas
que le québec avait tort de parler de
sixième vague mais disait tout
simplement que c'est difficile d'avoir
une vague qui se répercute de la même
façon partout donc on a choisi
d'utiliser d'autres mots mais le message
central de la santé publique fédérale
aujourd'hui c'était de dire le virus il
est encore ici pour un bout de temps
donc va falloir faire attention pour un
doute oui le message de prudence en le
même qu'on entend de toute façon dans
toutes les provinces où on nous dit même
si pas obligatoire
prenez donc pas de risque pour y est
j'aimerais vivre avec le virus bah voilà
ça c'est la phrase la france devrait
être finalement madeleine sébacées merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir 20h
semaine bonne cette semaine à rome pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit